with dignity and respect
committed to free speech turning
straight talking and direct we may edit
eight each other and you thought
provoking provocative and controversial
[Music]
hello and welcome to the pledge as I
know it can be hard to get your voice
heard when talking about brexit nowadays
it feels like we've hit saturation point
enter pro-eu campaigner Victoria Bateman
who's come up with a striking way this
week to get herself noticed appearing
across the media completely starkers
to make various points about brexit
leaving britain naked so in coming up on
the program okay what rachel makes us
self decent on the program today Carol
says Megan is no Diana June argues we
should all go with the flow when talking
about how Nick thinks the Defense
Secretary is in the realms of fantasy
and I'm going back to basics but first
back to Rachel thank you everybody
I carry no brief for Topshop billionaire
Sir Philip green and I speak as someone
who's met the man and I'm not defending
him from allegation that he has racially
abused or harassed his staff either the
alleged incidents include unwanted
contact of a sexual nature general
sexual harassment racist language
intimidation and bullying but we now
know several former employees have been
paid off after signing NDA's
non-disclosure agreements to keep schtum
about their alleged treatment hmm if you
want to bring a bully to account
don't take the massive pay off and sign
the NDA so you can never talk about it
again we don't know who the telegraph
sources are or if any of those who
signed NDA's broke them by speaking to
the press but if Sir Philip green had
forked out a million pounds for calling
me faintly sexual term I'd be laughing
all the way to the bank he may be a
foul-mouthed bully who's on the wrong
side of the me2 movement but he's paid
through the nose he's on the right side
of the law to sort out his HR problems
also he thought cause to strip him of
his knighthood and even face criminal
charges are both vindictive and wrong
[Music]
well Rachel what an exciting precedent
you've said for those of us who have to
do the introductions to the show God
knows what we're going to do with Uncle
Phil Campion right let's come to I think
the most well there's many things that
are interesting here let's talk a little
bit about these MDAs because I think you
might have some legal training and
there's a very interesting aspect of
NDA's because for the purpose of debate
let's say there's a very Saint now and
NDA's disposed not just personal matters
but also professional matters as well so
you have say a very very senior
executive of Sky News who's got all the
battle plans for brexit the general
election whatever else it might be he
she is then lured to go and work for the
BBC or write in you want to protect your
privacy so that's where I see the value
of an NDA the whole issue of NDA
interesting point because they can be
used for that there and they can be used
potentially we don't know potentially
bias to Philip green for other man so
how do we do and I would have thought
most of us because it all worked in
different parts of the media and we
probably all been in parts charged with
various plans and we've known about
office you know secrets or whatever how
do we keep the legality of an NDA for a
business that wants to keep a new
product a new type of razor blade a new
type of car a new breakfast cereal that
they don't want to lose the opposition
and I think we'd all agree with that and
I totally share your concerns that
potentially potentially serious matters
of a sexual nature or others are somehow
be good that's what I think we have to
try and wrestle with is your point how
do we know what was in the NDA was it
just the sort of the allegations and
then other stuff related to the business
I see the value of NDA for professional
for business for commercial interest
about allegations right right but the
whole question of NDA's I sense because
I think that with the me - movement and
lots of people have signed NDA's
question mark has been raised over
whether NDA's are ethical okay should
you forced an employee to sign them yeah
now I agree when it's you know
commercial sensitivity and a when
someone's leaving a company I think they
have to sign them yeah but I don't think
employ should be forced to sign that but
once they have signed them I think that
and been paid for sign it you can't have
your cake appraised at your stance on
this because I think you're on the side
of the movement to meet a movement or
you're not and I just and I think but I
think it is black and white I'm not and
I really thought it would be for you but
but but I I don't think it's okay for
rich men to use the law to protect
themselves from allegations of abuse and
I I think that he hasn't paid he's paid
that we've heard he's paid people large
sums of money to keep quiet now you know
yes there's something about the girls
yes okay they shouldn't have taken the
money they should have taken us down but
actually the thing is a million quids a
lot of money however I'm very
uncomfortable about this you know I'm
I'm probably unlike a lot of women in
that that I'm very tolerant of what a
lot of people call banter with men I
mean I you know because I think this
ludicrous to some of it and however what
what has been alleged here makes me feel
very uncomfortable in this case because
it's not just about abuse it's about
fear it's about the allegations are
about fear and about bullying and about
people on me wanted to dress in a suit
and that to me means he should not be
protected by the law in any way shape I
think this has magistrates you of it so
Philip has quotes categorically denied
any unlawful racist or sexual behavior
as lawyers say and I quote again it is
further denied that any of the Philips
conduct towards employees amount to any
type of crime or anything that would
amount to grow
misconduct or serious risks to health
and safety in a statement issued after
the ruling Sir Philip and the board of
the Arcadia group said the signatories
to the non-disclosure agreements were
under quotes ongoing obligations close
quotes to honor the agreements the
statement continued the Telegraph has
pursued a vendetta against the Philip
green and the employees and management
of Arcadia group for the past nine
months harassing many of its staff and
their families in their homes often at
night on the weekends
The Telegraph and its owners must now
decide whether to do the decent thing
and respect the NDA's right so before I
comment from my perspective let's have a
listen to somebody who has made
allegations and Irving who worked for
Topshop in LA if we're setting an
example and suggesting that this type of
behavior is okay well times that by you
know sir Philips not the only wealthy
individual in the world there's there's
a lot of men out there and I'd hope that
we're not utilizing this individual as
an example of how men with money should
should act and more or less hide behind
a piece of paper so that of course sir
Philips defence team have described her
as an unreliable witness and that the
jury is out there but I would like to
say I think actually clearly there is a
place for any haze in terms of
controversy and that's really important
when criminal allegations are involved
normally even even where NDA's aren't
involved there is often a civil
settlement and a criminal case to be
made and they are often separated and so
I I do wonder why even in the case of
NDA's when money has been made to take
Carol's point why why we can't separate
the two there as well so even if you
paid a million pounds to somebody that's
for the civil compensation which often
accompanies many criminal cases why
should why should they get let off
scot-free for any alleged and potential
is lining up to see criminal offences
have been committed and they've actually
named what those offences could be but
do you do you not think what I find
really disappointing in all of this is
the whole the big the big swathe of
celebrity women who Philip Creon has
been involved with over the years
they've all kept incredibly quiet about
this and I find this really
disappointing and they're all women if
you look at it I'm not going to name
them because I'm not allowed to but it
but if you look at all of these women
they've all been
in the pictures okay so you know we know
that all of these women have in the past
being paid large sums of money by
filigreed are still being paid or have
taken and his wife for many years and
have done lots of work for Topshop the
New York saw a launch I did all of that
and and what I do you know the lady that
we just heard from no but I know a lot
of the women that open - can we
crystallize here yeah I mean those two
questions have been brought up over all
these allegations that have the
Telegraph and we should actually
acknowledge that the Telegraph's owners
the Barclays brothers have been in
dispute over a deal they did with Sir
Philip Green over the sale of Sears and
Sevilla green called them old codgers
and boasted that he had got his a better
end of the deal the question to me is
very simple you know if he has is he if
he's guilty of crime then I think he has
to face charges but they people have to
bring those charges in plain sight which
made me breaking their NDA they have to
deal with that separately yeah the
second issue which arose in the commons
assignment is in whether he should be
stripped of his knighthood now this is
quite pre-emptive because a forfeiture
committee but let's hear what the Prime
Minister has to say and then I want to
what yes it's important but if the
recipient of an honour brings that
honour into disrepute steps should be
taken to review that honor now that of
course there is a forfeiture process for
that purpose that does include an
independent forfeiture committee which
gives recommendations to me for Her
Majesty's approval that is the that is
the process but it's important I believe
that we have that so that anybody who
has been in receipt of an honor that
brings honor into a disrepute that steps
can be taken to review that is he guilty
of trial by media and that is he a
victim of trial by me and this is where
I agree with you I think when it comes
to allegations if we are not able to
prove that the allegations are actually
true then he shouldn't be stripped of
his honour but if a criminal case were
to arise and he was convicted and of
course he should be stripped of his
honour
and like I said I've known Philip for a
very long time now I've never seen
racial abuse and I've never seen sexual
harassment what I have seen is
aggressive behavior he isn't going
respect but a lot of businessman he's a
very aggressive man he shouts a lot but
being a bully it's not against the law
exactly being a boisterous bully yeah
it's not against the law put your shirt
on yes well don't